do you have advice for people a lot a
lot a lot of young people look up to you
give advice for young people
of how to live a life they can be proud
of
don't tweet while you're sleepy
take a nap
surely there's other things I love the
humor don't take it seriously I suppose
is what that means
no don't send sleepy tweets uh unless
you buy your own social platform the
very next week call parlor but other
than that if you're not gonna buy your
own social plan then is that why you
bought parlors so you could be sleepy
and send messages out into the wild
I actually am really interested in the
engineering aspects of parlor is there a
vision there because I'm also super
interested in Elon buying Twitter I like
Instagram
uh better than Twitter
and I'm sure Mark Zuckerberg liked
Instagram better than Facebook or saw
how
uh you know how valuable that was and he
bought it so you'd like to take Paul or
something whatever is the magic that
makes Instagram work you want to push
well I thought it was interesting how it
felt like Snapchat made the Kardashians
bully Instagram what what's the what's
the point of Snapchat going to war
one on Instagram
yeah I mean just everyone wants to say
well this is our value Snapchat you know
no one wants to lose their value to
someone else's value whatever it's like
and everything is just what's the
difference between permanent and
temporary
you know is this the permanent structure
and until God says it's not you know
it's like nothing's permanent our life
is not permanent
so how do we just let go those things
even like going from the name Kanye West
to yay was the beginning of just letting
go
of some things of these titles like we
need to remove the titles like hey
if I if I have to leave Adidas and I
have to go next computers
that may take me out of the billionaire
standing all together
and I Gotta Get Low for however long God
says I have to get low and refocus I've
been
reshaping refocusing my staff
I had some people that were good and I
had some people that weren't I had too
many people and I've got a vision inside
of me and I'm like this is how I make
this Vision I have to bring this Vision
to life
I have to bring these houses to life I
was talking to
um one of our architects
on you know we're actually getting close
on it I've like built it a few times I
had like the domes you probably saw and
kind of and I said you know how he
transformed Kim's house and
you know we're getting there like so you
want to get into architecture like you
really you really want to become
physical reality yes and I've got close
Rome wasn't built to the day yeah but
Rome had to start somewhere yeah I gotta
call you out on the advice there really
is a lot of people that look up to you
and you've lived a really difficult life
and you made it through all of it
what what what do you advise them to do
do everything that you feel
even if you are told that it's the wrong
thing no no no no no but not anything
violent
should do what you feel say what you
feel like trust your heart yeah trust
your gut trust your instincts because
that instinct is who God made you to be
not you know what lines up with your
life frat brothers or what lines up with
what your dad wanted or what lines up
with your classmates or you know it's
just
God has something inside of you and when
you walk down the street you're thinking
about it and then you just see it in the
window
and you go down another stream you see
the same thing or you're thinking about
a number and that number pops up or you
see it on a license plate and that's
just
you know
something is trying to say be the
maximum
yay you know be the maximum you and God
will give you anything that you can't
handle so for me
everything is a yes I think they say Be
Like Water I know Bruce Lee said that
or matter of fact just be
because we are beings with engineering
opportunities
beautifully put